in high school I really did wear a
plastic pocket protector I really did
wear thick black glasses taped together
and this includes my Iran period and I
the social skills to go with all this
well I've been libertarian influence
ever since high school like many folks I
read a few things by ein r and even
making a pilgrimage to her offices and
this goes back about 40 years which is
horrifying to say even meeting Murray
Rothbard back then being a member of the
Society for individual liberty for some
years then drifting away because I sense
that oh sometimes a libertarian ideals
don't mesh well with the real world like
the market has failed to provide good
health care for people and if I believe
that I should treat people like I want
to be treated well that means trying to
get people a break but I do prefer
market solutions and that means I'm some
kind of hybrid libertarian I need a term
libertarian moderate is better than
nothing but it's not catchy enough
Marco's malesis calls himself a
libertarian Democrat but I'm a more of
an independent
first I
assure everyone that I do know the West
Wing is just a TV show and that i think
the west wing in a sense is predictive
of the new sense of idealism the
realistic idealism that says that people
can work together to make things better
in the country it's this sense of civic
engagement which the sociologists say is
a real thing among the youngsters
depending on whether you draw that line
art at 24 or 30 I see something
firsthand every day that there is this
new sense of engagement among the young
they're voting in great numbers and as
of yesterday Google by the way is
pushing this pushing voter registration
in a huge way and the idea is that
frankly i'm hoping the the kids will
bail out my baby boomer but and set
things right because we do have bad
things coming like the bill for Iraq the
bill for the financial bailout the bill
for Medicare and Social Security so the
west wing in a sense started pumping me
up as much as I'm capable of being
pumped up at my age for what's happening
with the Obama campaign right now
I have a very very minor role as part of
the Obama Technology Committee what I
focused on personally are some of the
efforts which relate to some of my
personal efforts both in my day job and
outside of that the big one is
accountability and transparency the deal
there is that I feel that pretty much
everything government does should be
disclosed online obviously there are
some areas like national security which
shouldn't be disclosed but most
everything else should be in particular
voting records should be disclosed
online campaign financing lobbyists
spending ultimately with the goal of
figuring out things like when lobbyists
spend money what does it get them
contracts legislation that kind of thing
sunlight foundation is the leader in
that and my disclosure that I'm on their
board the Obama campaign has come all
out for fairly complete transparency the
idea is that everything should be in the
light of day sunlight is the best
disinfectant the McCain campaign has
been silent about this however they seem
to be supportive of the Senate hold on a
measure which would expose a lot of
Senate campaign financing to the light
of day that sent it to 23 which is being
held by Senators Mitch McConnell and
John Henson apparently with McCain's
complicity so they're hiding something
it allows people to get stuff done
whether it's commerce socializing and
politics the only way you know what's
going on is to have some sense of what's
happening on the net and to know how
people communicate if you don't have a
sense of that and if you don't have
someone catching the buzz on the
internet you're hopelessly out of touch
doing customer service for over 13 years
I see that people are overwhelmingly
trustworthy there are bad guys out there
not a lot of them and people know to
look out for each other and to look out
for the bad guys so people have this
expectation of trust despite what we
feel sometimes and the net facilitates
that when you're on the net if you're
paying attention you'll see bad guys out
there but if you think about it you see
far more trustworthy people out there
the news industry I think is doing
pretty well big newspapers national ones
doing well very local ones are doing
well the ones in the middle not so well
but a lot of that has to do with the
costs of using paper expensive to buy
print and deliver meanwhile the net is
becoming a better and better medium for
news I do think the big challenges for
news operations will be to remember what
their strengths are and to see what
happens as new forms of media merge with
traditional media the biggest strength
of traditional media when they do it is
fact checking the biggest strength of
new media is speaking truth to power I
think news organizations of all sorts
need to do really good fact-checking
improve quality and speak truth to power
for example when a politician is telling
you a lie and you know it's a lie say so
when you want to have people to give you
opinions on a story if the only person
who can express their side of the story
is known to be a professional in the art
of deception don't give that person a
voice if you know they're going to lie
to you things need to be fixed
cones music and poetry is the closest
thing I have to prayer and listening to
it well it inspires a certain idealism
if you know the guys words talk to you
because he's not for everyone i guess
and the deal is that he is and helped
renew that sense of idealism which I
thought I'd lost as a kid that ain't bad
basically he's my rabbi
people are not as a materialistic as we
think people share a lot of the same
values like that treat people like you
want to be treated thing and you know
whether that's whether I'm hearing it
from a small town person or a big city
person across the country people do
share the same values more or less I
just don't get this culture war thing
because people disagree about some
things but it's just this agreement
unless someone comes along and picks a
fight